[Music]
the oldest shoe archaeologists have ever
found is a fifty-five hundred year old
leather hide moccasin with leather cord
laces today we don't have to go hunt an
animal to lace our shoes we can buy our
shoelaces ready-made in a variety of
materials styles lengths and colors this
company produces shoe laces as shoelace
type drawstrings and a wide range of
materials including cotton rayon and
acrylic this run is producing polyester
shoelaces a worker installs cones of
fine polyester thread on what's called a
Creole which feeds the bobbin winding
machines she groups the strands from 8
cones and feeds them through one side of
one machine and onto a bobbin then she
groups the strands from another 8 cones
and feeds them through the other side of
the machine onto a second bobbin each
group of eight strands will produce one
thicker polyester thread she programs
the machine to wind a specific length of
it each cone holds enough fine thread to
wind a 71 mile long thick thread for
this particular shoelace the machine is
programmed to wind 8200 feet of thick
thread per bobbin
another worker installs 20 of those
bobbins on a braiding machine for each
one she passes the end of the thread
through three eyelets the second of
which regulates the tension of the
thread
she gathers half the threats and ties
knots in them so that they'll catch when
she feeds them into the machine she
starts up the braiding machine it draws
in the knotted threads which pulled in
the unknotted once then the machine
begins braiding a continuous round
shoelace cord these wheels apply tension
to pull any loose braids tighter so that
the cord diameter is uniform the
finished cord which is about a mile long
collects in a barrel some shoelaces are
made of knitted rather than braided cord
the cones of thread feed the knitting
machine directly the machines for latch
needles can perform two types of
knitting stitches to produce round cord
once the knitted or braided cord is
ready
a worker adjusts for metal pegs of a
winding device to the shoelace length or
making then she winds the cord around
the pegs up to 250 times depending on
the cord diameter
she cuts the end and ties the cords
together so that she can easily transfer
them to what's called a tipping machine
[Music]
she runs the center of each chord over
an acetone saturated felt pad then
inserts it in the machines dye the dye
wraps a piece of acetate film tightly
around the cord then cuts it in the
middle producing a shoelace with the
stiff tip called an aglet on each end
this press applies a nickel-plated steel
tip a kind used on bag drawstrings
the worker manually positions two tips
directly on the cord with a slight gap
in between them she activates the press
to force them on then cuts the cord in
the gap this Factory also makes rickrack
a flat zigzag trim that's sewn onto
clothing these rickrack braiding
machines are 120 years old each one
holds from 13 to 73 bobbins of thread
the more bobbins used the wider the
rickrack
there are two ways to make multicolored
rickrack or braided shoelace cord mount
different shades of solid color bobbins
on the braiding machine or wind
multicolored thread on each bobbin and
for multicolored knitted shoelace cord
mount different shades of solid color
thread cones or multicolored thread on
each cone to produce different shapes
and sizes this manufacturer uses
different types of braiding and knitting
machines varying the number of bobbins
or combs from eight to as many as 73 an
even number produces a round shoelace an
odd number produces a flat one with so
many possibilities shoelaces can be
fashionable as well as functional